in den frühen Morgenstunden mit
dreistündiger Verspätung allerdings in
Warschau angekommen aus Kiew kommt ich
hatte dort ein sehr sehr interessanten
Aufenthalt mit vielen guten Gesprächen
und mit sehr tiefgehenden Eindrücken ich
bin hingefahren um mir in den ersten
zwei Wochen meine Amtszeit etwas mehr
ein persönliches Bild zu machen von der
Situation von der Kriegslage in der
Ukraine ich habe mit Präsident silenski
gesprochen und in meinem Amtskollegen
olexiekoff und ich habe mir vor allen
Dingen einen Eindruck gemacht über das
tägliche Geschehen was dort zu
beobachten ist indem ich zum Beispiel
eine Stellung eines gepard-panzers
besucht habe und nicht mit den dort
tätigen Soldaten
gesprochen habe und der Eindruck den ich
dort gewinnen konnte war ein sehr sehr
guter ich war gerade zu angetan von der
Schnelligkeit in der sich die
ukrainischen Besatzung auf diese
Waffensysteme eingestellt haben wie
schnell sie darauf ausgebildet werden
konnten und wie gut sie mit diesem
System umgehen und wie gut Sie zufrieden
sind mit diesen Systemen die sehr
effektiv sind in der Flugabwehr
abgerundet wurde dieser Teil mit einem
Eindruck der mich besonders berührt hat
die nicht für dich gewonnen habe durch
Gespräche mit denen Soldaten der
ukrainischen Armee die jetzt auf dem Weg
nach Deutschland sind um unter anderem
in Münster überwiegend ausgebildet zu
werden am Leopard 2 A6
und diese Eindrücke die ich dort
gewonnen habe so will ich es mal
formulieren sagen mehr als 1.000 Worte
ich habe in sehr sehr ernste Gesichter
geguckt im Gesichter die gerade zu
beschrieben haben erzählt haben was
hinter diesen Männern überwiegend Männer
waren es das hinter ihnen liegt 70%
derjenigen die vor mir gesessen haben
kamen gerade von der Front unter anderem
bachmut und anderswo und ähm Reisen
jetzt direkt weiter zur Ausbildung und
wissen dass sie danach wieder an die
Front gehen und so ernst die Gesichter
waren so geprägt sie waren von den
Erlebnissen die mit Sicherheit hinter
ihnen lagen so entschlossen waren die
Gesichter aber auch und brachten zum
Ausdruck wir geben nicht nach und das
ist ein Zeichen was ich sehr
bewundernswert finde und man kann es
glaube ich so formulieren die Menschen
in der Ukraine die Soldaten und Soldaten
erteilen der Welt teilen Russland aber
auch der Welt eine Lektion in Sachen Mut
und Wehrhaftigkeit und
Durchhaltevermögen und ich sag's für
mich aber auch für die deutsche
Bevölkerung wir blicken mit Demut und
Respekt auf diese Leistung dieses
Engagement und dieses Durchhaltevermögen
es hat mir aber auch gezeigt
wie wichtig die Deutschen die
europäischen und die NATO
Unterstützungsleistungen sind
insbesondere die Deutschen und die
europäischen und natürlich die der
Amerikaner
wir helfen als Deutschland jetzt mit der
im März anstehenden Lieferung von
Leopard Panzern Leopard 185 werden aus
der Industrie kommen dazu haben sich
Deutschland gemeinsam mit den
Niederlanden und Belgien und Dänemark
entschieden eine sehr sehr schöne
Entwicklung die die Widerstand zum
Verteidigungsfähigkeit der Ukraine noch
einmal steigen wird und mit Polen haben
wir ebenfalls ein gemeinsames Projekt
Deutschland wird zwei Leopard A6 liefern
Polen wird sich um die zwei A4 kümmern
und wir haben gerade verabredet mein
Kollege Marius dass wir gemeinsam mit
Alexi resnikow auf dem ukrainischen
Verteidigungsminister für nächste Woche
wieder zu einem Treffen der Länder
einladen die diese Koalition aus zwei A4
und 286 Panzern bilden sollen ich freue
mich sehr über dieses Signal einer
gemeinsamen Einladung weil es wichtig
ist noch mal zu dokumentieren dass wir
noch nicht am Ziel sind hier gibt es
noch Luft nach oben was einige Länder
angegeben
wir hoffen sehr dass sich aus dieser
Initiative heraus dann mehr Leopard
Nationen anschließen
es ist jetzt ein wichtiger den Weg dass
wir wirklich alle Hebel in Bewegung
setzen und alle Mittel die noch nicht
aktiviert sind bemühen damit die Ukraine
in ihrer Verteidigung gegen Russland
unterstützt werden kann
ich habe gerade jetzt hier mein Gespräch
mit Blasche
beendet und ich freue mich über ein
Gespräch das jetzt schon das dritte war
zwei persönliche hatten wir eines der
WTC
und das war ein sehr sehr offenes und
ehrliches Gespräch und ich wünsche mir
mehr solcher Gespräche wir haben
gesprochen über die Zusammenarbeit über
die Möglichkeiten die noch auszubauen
ich mir war aber vor allen Dingen
wichtig auch ein Zeichen zu setzen
dieses ist jetzt ich bin morgen drei
Wochen im Amt das ist mein erster
bilateraler Besuch bei einem
Nato-Partner und der führt mich nach
Warschau und das ist kein Zufall sondern
seine bewusste Entscheidung um deutlich
zu machen welche Bedeutung ich den
Beziehungen zu Polen insgesamt einräume
ein äh zugestehe und einräumen und sie
sehe gleichzeitig aber auch
weiß um welche welche Verantwortung wir
gemeinsam reden denn ich glaube das ist
uns allen klar es gibt so etwas wie eine
deutsch-polnische Interessengemeinschaft
wir haben viele sich überschneidende
Interessen nicht zuletzt verteidigungs-
und sicherheitspolitisch nicht zuletzt
was die Frage der Sicherung der
Ostflanke angeht und natürlich
insbesondere auch was die Unterstützung
der Ukraine angeht da sind wir uns
vollkommen einig und ich freue mich sehr
dass wir in diesem Dialog heute da einen
Schritt weitergekommen sind und wir
haben mit dem Kontext natürlich auch
darüber gesprochen wie wir die deutsche
Rüstungsindustrie
dazu bringen können die Produktion zu
erhöhen wie sie mehr produzieren kann
denn wir werden mehr Ersatzteile und
Munition brauchen insbesondere für zwei
A4 und 1 A5
und besonders wichtig war uns beiden
auch dass wir unsere Einigkeit betonen
bei allen Differenzen die es in der ein
oder anderen Frage geben mag das ist
normal entscheidend ist aber in dieser
Phase in der wir sind ein einheitliches
ein geschlossenes Bild dass wir nach
außen liefern in dem was wir tun aber
auch in dem was wir machen
ich habe außerdem vorher einen sehr
gutes Gespräch geführt mit dem
Vorsitzenden des polnischen
sicherheitsbüros
wir haben beide unser beiderseitiges
Interesse und das gilt übrigens auch für
Markus blaszak daran zum Ausdruck
gebracht die Gespräche die es bis vor
einiger Zeit regelmäßig gab also auf
Fachebene zwischen den politischen
Direktoren den Experten wieder zu
beleben weil ich glaube dass gerade in
diesen Zeiten der regelmäßige Austausch
auf allen Ebenen von zentraler Bedeutung
ist
in übrig bleibt mir dann nur noch zu
sagen dass ich
dass ich sehr sehr froh bin über den
offenen Austausch dass wir verabredet
haben den vorzusetzen im Interesse
unserer tatsächlich gemeinsam
festgestellt und Interessenslagen und
deswegen bin ich Marius und Ariana sehr
dankbar für die offenen Gespräche an
deren Fortsetzung ich als Deutscher
Verteidigung des Minister ein sehr sehr
vitales Interesse haben vielen Dank Herr
Minister sie haben es schon angesprochen
es Stichwort Leopard was ist mit denen
was ist ihre Botschaft an die Staaten
die Kapazitäten haben aber bisschen noch
nicht bereit sind die zur Verfügung zu
stellen gerade jetzt wo sie selber aus
der Ukraine wiederkommen
ich habe zunächst mal für jeden
Verständnis der seine Verpflichtung der
Landesverteidigung unser
bündnisverteidigung mit dem Auge habe
das tun wir als Deutschland auch und das
tut Polen auch das auch notwendig und
das ist richtig gleichzeitig geht es
immer um die Frage wie viel wie viel
Panzer sind einsatzbereit wie ist die
ersatzteilage die Ersatzteile
beschaffungslage und die munitionslage
und auch die Frage der Instandsetzung
spielt eine zentrale Rolle deswegen
finde ich es völlig legitim dass der ein
oder andere noch überlegt wie er das
herstellen kann deswegen dient das
Treffen nächste Woche in Brüssel auch
dazu hier noch mal ihr Interessen
zusammenzuführen und zu fragen und zu
klären wo wir wem behilflich sein können
und das wird wesentlicher Tenor
wesentlich erinnert das Gespräch nächste
Woche wieder
jetzt weitere Fragen ja
das ist sehr wichtig diese Einheit die
sie spielen und man hat sie heute
überhaupt nicht zusammen gesehen hier im
amtsgeregt dass wir eher
Ungewöhnlichkeit und
er ist jetzt nicht dabei
sein darf nicht zu äußern
[Musik]
die Ukraine hat aber den gestrigen Tag
nicht erwähnt wie irritiert ich bin da
völlig völlig gelassen und völlig frei
von Irritation wir haben gerade noch
sehr sehr lange gesprochen und auch
unter vier Augen noch kurz er musste
jetzt ins Parlament wegen Abstimmung
deswegen konnte er jetzt nicht mit dir
dabei ich nehme das völlig gelassen
jeder muss seinen Job da gerade machen
wo er gefordert ist ich habe keine keine
Scheu auch alleine vor sie zu treten und
zu berichten worüber wir gesprochen
haben und das Gespräch war eben so wie
ich geschrieben habe eines der klarsten
und ehrlichsten Gespräche die man sich
vorstellen kann und das ist notwendig in
diesen Zeiten und darauf kommt es
letztlich an deswegen ist es auch
verständlich wahrscheinlich auch für Sie
dass wir nicht über alle Details weder
ich jetzt hier noch eher anderswo
großartig ausführt
und was der dezente Hinweis darauf zu
bedeuten hat dass es nur 14 Leopard
zweier sechs sind auch damit gehe ich
gelassen um denn wir haben eine hohe
Verpflichtung zur Bündnis und
Landesverteidigung und die nützt auch
Polen und nützt auch der Ostflanke und
deswegen ist das glaube ich am Ende
verständlich dass er sich mehr gewünscht
hat verstehe ich wünschte mir von
anderen auch mehr
ähm
Action
Batterien
Tanks
the science
Baby
year and in the next hier
count on following Tours
one
jetzt schön
Reparation sagt man nicht wie sagt man
[Musik]
Kommunikationssystem z.B haben wir auch
darüber gesprochen darüber haben wir
heute nicht gesprochen aber darüber
haben ja
darüber haben wir heute nicht gesprochen
das ist ein Thema gewesen unter den
Experten auch mit der Rüstungsindustrie
die Frage der Kommunikation sowohl unter
den verschiedenen Leo zwei Typen aber
auch den Leos mit den Mardern auch
darauf kommt sie an in den Verbänden das
ist gerade in der technischen Klärung
und wird mit Sicherheit dann bis im März
auch gelöst sein weitere Fragen
ja dann haben wir es vielen dank vielen
Dank
und das war Boris Pistorius vor ungefähr
40 Minuten klar und ehrlich hat er
gesprochen das wollen wir jetzt auch tun
mit Kristin Joachim dekorrespondentin im
Studio Warschau Frau Joachim wenn wir
grundsätzlich erstmal schauen das war
das dritte Mal dass Herr Pistorius
seinem
Amtskollegen seinen polnischen
Amtskollegen begegnet ist aber es war
Formel dann so etwas wie der
Antrittsbesuch allerdings durchaus mit
einer gewissen begleitmelodie wie wir in
den letzten Tagen und Wochen spüren
konnten in welcher Atmosphäre hat dieses
Gespräch stattgefunden es gab ja nun
keine gemeinsame Presse Begegnung
ja ganz genau also man kann das ja schon
hören daran was Pistorius gerade gesagt
hat dass Gespräch mit seinem polnischen
Amtskollegen sei eins der klarsten und
ehrlichsten Gespräche gewesen die er je
geführt hat und ich glaube dass lässt
darauf schließen dass da auch einige
sehr kritische Punkte angesprochen
wurden gerade von polnischer Seite er
hat das jetzt als durchaus positiv
dargestellt grundsätzlich muss man sagen
dass dieses diese dieser Besuch doch in
einer sehr in eine sehr schwierige Zeit
gefallen ist das hat einmal durchaus
auch ein bisschen mit der Person Boris
Pistorius zu tun klar sieht man nach dem
seine Vorgängerin als sehr sehr kritisch
gesehen wurde da die sehr zögerlich bei
den Waffenlieferung bei der Aufrüstung
der Bundeswehr wahrgenommen wurde sagt
man eigentlich das kann nur besser
werden aber gleichzeitig gibt es eine
gewisse Skepsis auch gegen Boris
Pistorius der so sagt es zumindest auch
der Ministerpräsident Polens Matheus
maraviewski gleich zu zum Amtsantritt
von Boris Pistorius er sei ein enger
Mitarbeiter des Symbols der Schande ger
Schröder man würde ihm jetzt natürlich
aber noch ein paar Tage Zeit geben um
dieses Bild zurechtzurücken also da
sieht man erstmal dass er natürlich auch
in diese ist das ganze Thema SPD
Russland Nähe gerückt wird und da jetzt
erstmal in diesen Ruf loswerden muss
grundsätzlich aber ist der Ruf
Deutschlands hat der in Polen sehr sehr
gelitten seit Beginn des Krieges es geht
immer wieder darum das zu zögerlich zu
wenig Unterstützung militärische
Unterstützung für die Ukraine gezeigt
wurde und natürlich sieht man es auch
ganz klar daran dass es kein gemeinsames
Präsident von polnischen und deutschen
Verteidigungsminister beim ersten ähm am
Abend Antrittsbesuch gegeben hat es gab
auch keine gemeinsamen Bilder und das
auch wenn man das im Zusammenhang mit
dem Wahlkampf der hier in Polen schon
stattfindet sie muss ist es schon ein
ziemlich deutliches Zeichen Frau Joachim
das was sie zitiert haben Herr
moraviewski im Grunde genommen die
politische Elite des Landes also noch
einmal Blick auf Deutschland zögerlicher
Haltung im Frage von panzerlieferung von
Waffenlieferung ganz allgemein das ist
ja wirklich ein schrittweises Verfahren
gewesen sie betrachten natürlich als
Korrespondentin auch die gesamte
polnische Öffentlichkeit ist das jetzt
nur noch die politische Elite des Landes
die sehr verärgert auf Deutschland
schaut oder wie breit muss man das
Denken
nein das ist durchaus auch eigentlich
bei fast allen Menschen hier mit zu
hören mit dem man ins Gespräch kommt das
allen möglichen Bereichen es ist sowohl
die politische Opposition aber es sind
auch ganz normale Menschen die hier
einfach schon das Gefühl haben dass
Deutschland den Ernst der Lage nicht
erkennt natürlich ist es so dass das
Polen als Frontstaat sehr viel näher
dran ist am Kriegsgeschehen das
vergangenen November ist ja eine
fehlgeleitete Rakete auf polnisches
Territorium gelandet und hat zwei Bürger
zwei Mensch Menschen hier getötet das
ist natürlich noch mal eine ganz andere
Sache und natürlich auch mit Blick auf
die Geschichte die Polen mit Russland
hat sieht man Russland als wesentlich
größere Bedrohungen wir wissen alle dass
Polen viele viele Jahre schon gewarnt
hat vor einer ähm vor einer Abhängigkeit
von Russland Thema Nord Stream 1 und 2
und man findet natürlich jetzt muss viel
viel mehr getan werden das ist auch
unser Krieg der in der Ukraine geführt
wird sagen die Polen hier und das geht
wirklich durch alle Bereiche sie werden
das weiter für uns im Blick behalten
insbesondere auch diese expliziten
Vorbereitungen für weitere
Waffenlieferungen vielen Dank für die
Einschätzung am heutigen Nachmittag an
Kristin Joachim ARD Korrespondentin im
Studio Warschau herzlichen Dank gern